ob man den großbritannien da flutscht es
mit dem impfen und hier in deutschland
haben wir so große probleme bei der
beschaffung des impfstoffs und ganz
genauso bei der organisation der ganzen
impftermine davon kann ein lied singt
uwe lühr ich aus götting mit dem ich
jetzt verbunden bin ich grüße sie herr
lürig guter weise bei ihnen wären
eigentlich ihre eltern dran gewesen mit
dem impfen da lief aber einiges schief
bei der organisation der im termin
erzählen sie mal meine mutter hat im
januar auf einem brief gewartet dass sie
sich endlich zum impfen anmelden kann
sie hat dann einen brief bekommen
allerdings adressiert an meinen vater
der bereits am 22 november verstorben
ist sie hat reingeguckt und hat sich
gewundert dass er die aufforderung hatte
sich am 28
zum impfen anzumelden und hat auch bis
heute gewartet dass hier auch noch einen
brief bekommt aber hat keinen bekommen
das heißt also ihr verstorbener vater
sollte diesen impftermin bekommen und
diejenige die ist wirklich gebraucht
hätte ihre mutter die wartet bis heute
auf einen entsprechenden termin ganz
genau sie kann sich noch nicht
angemeldet man ist es ja gesagt wollen
sie sollte ich ein paar unter der
adresse ihres ehemannes an werden aber
das kann ja auch nicht der richtige weg
sein was alles schief läuft hätte ich
nicht sagen aber in diesem fall läuft
einiges schief weil ich auch viele
rückmeldungen aus bekanntenkreis
bekommen habe die alle gesagt haben sie
kennen auch fälle wo verstorbene
angeschrieben worden
hinter krass ist der fall war ein
bekannter dessen vater vor vier jahren
gestorben ist auch der hat diesen brief
bekommen und das kann natürlich nicht
sagen das muss man auch in aller
deutlichkeit herausstellen
jetzt sehen wir das in unseren
nachbarländern dass es da viel viel
besser läuft zb in großbritannien da
gibt es einfach eine sms aufs handy
da kriegt man so einen impftermin und
dann wird man auch sehr schnell geimpft
jeden weiß ich von ihm sie sind
polizeichef in götting das heißt sie
sind immer dafür da die regeln
durchzusetzen und vor allen dingen auch
an den staat wirklich zu glauben aber
der funktioniert gerade in dieser im
krise nicht richtig verlieren sie so ein
stück zumindest von ihrem glauben gerade
leute glauben verliere ich glaube ich
nicht aber das vertrauen verliere ich
schon ein klein wenig ich kann nur sagen
das was ich auch aus meinem
bekanntenkreis
und aus dem nachbarschafts kreis höre
dass man eben dieses vertrauen verloren
hat
ich bin kein querdenker ich habe alle
maßnahmen mitgemacht ich achte auch
darauf dass die kontakt beschränkungen
eingehalten werden ich bin der erste mit
maske herumgelaufen ist aber ich erwarte
jetzt auch das langsam die impfungen
beginnen und zwar auch strukturiert und
nach einem system
danke an uwe lürig der selbst schlechte
erfahrungen gemacht hat gerade bei der
vergabe dieser impftermine und der im
zuge dieses image desaster sagt mensch
ich verliere gerade auch wenn ich
polizeichef bin hier in götting ein
bisschen an vertrauen
herzlichen dank herr lürig geschehen